he's a stand-up comedian and on October
17th Brian will co-star along with Ron
Livingston we like Ron Peter Farrelly
the TV series Loudermilk on the audience
network so big TV star there November 11
Brian Regan makes his Carnegie Hall
debut look at you doing big boy things
there I'm going to be in the audience in
Carnegie Hall you are yes yeah so you're
not on stage you no no no I'm going to
go there and see a show I don't know
who's going to be that it's not true
he's got to Netflix stand-up series
specials this one I have a deal for two
one-hour specials one of them will be
coming out in November and the other one
will be coming out in a couple years all
right
I mentioned this a couple of times and
glad that word got back to you but Mike
children when they were growing up
younger turned me on to your comedy
tapes your CDs I'm very honored and
driving in the car when you're trying to
get kids to you know not fight each
other and I just would like they would
give this this laughs this guttural
laugh like a belly laugh out loud where
you're snorting and I just remember
listening to those tapes and my kids go
can we go see him he's going to be in
Stanford Connecticut I said okay and I
said to my wife do we have to worry
about language here and she said no Wow
and then so we sat in the audience and
then I it was just one of those
experiences where I went you know what I
wonder if people know there's great
comedy without it being sexual innuendo
or double entendre it was just you
you're very bright and seeing things in
a unique way a fun way and it was it was
fun for an entire family which is kind
of rare that's very very kind of you
thank you very much I like to work that
way on stage but on radio I'm happy good
so buckle up but but when we just played
you're a must win situation but are you
a sports fan I I played football when I
was young I like to play golf
occasionally I ran track and field when
I was in high school I know a little bit
about sports but I would not consider
myself an avid sports fan how much
sports would you incorporate in stand-up
like why must-win situation did you
incorporate that what was it about
you just said because it always drove me
crazy when I when I heard that question
being asked
I would like want to come through the TV
every time I would hear somebody ask
that question so that that kind of thing
just jumps out at me
and then you write it do you write it
down and then all of a sudden say
alright now I like you have certain
things topics and you go okay now let me
extrapolate here and come up with yes
yes like another one that I've been
doing recently is the when an athlete
jumps up and says that's what I'm
talking about you know well how do I
know you know I think they should be
required to show the proof so I have
this thing where like if they make a
good catch in the corner of the endzone
and say that's what I'm talking about
they should whip out an iPad in fact
this is me from an interview just last
evening and then show the guy go through
the whole motions where he describes
this incredible catch he's going to make
see that's what I was talking about so
you just see little things like that you
go maybe there's something funny there I
don't know when you were growing up who
did you look at listened to and all of a
sudden something clicked and you said
can I do this can I be this well I
always liked comedy when I was a kid my
mom and dad are very funny all my
brothers and sisters are funny and it's
a big family - yeah yeah eight kids and
you know so we used to you know be funny
around a house and then I used to like
you know staying up late and watch
Johnny Carson you know when he did his
monologues and stuff like that but in
terms of stand-up comedians I used to
really like watching guys do a stand-up
set it was or women it was always
intriguing to me to watch someone do
stand-up and some of the people that
popped out of the bigger names obviously
like Steve Martin and George Carlin and
Richard Pryor but there were some more
obscure guys like a Kelly Monteith I
don't know if you remember there's a guy
named Kelly Monteith who he might still
be doing stand-up who I just thought was
incredibly funny he had this bit about
driving down the road and seeing one
shoe in the median and he said I just
don't get that he goes I can understand
two shoes
or no shoes I don't understand one shoe
and he had this whole thing about a guy
driving on tired of this shoe and he
would take the shoe and throw it out the
window this one I like that's what I'm
keeping that one I've had enough of so I
mean I would see things like that when I
was young and go that's funny to me
because I've seen lone shoes on in the
median and the fact that somebody would
somebody else would notice that and come
up with a joke about that was always
fascinating to me but you have to tell
your parents at some point this is what
I want to do for a living mmm-hmm how
did that go over I was ten credit hours
shy of graduating from Heidelberg
college and I knew I wasn't going to
make it you know I was like coming up to
the the finish line of a marathon and I
wasn't going to quite get there I knew I
wanted to do stand-up and from what
little I knew about it I knew you didn't
need a degree you know you don't show up
at the Chuckle house and they're not
going to go where's your sheepskin so I
thought I'm just going to give this a
shot
and if it works out great if it doesn't
work out I can always go back and finish
the college thing if they gave out
degrees in comedy hmm like masters uh
you know like a Bachelor arts and
science like if you were if you're going
to do that like who would be magna [ __ ]
laude and summa [ __ ] laude a geek I know
you've never thought of this but it just
kind of popped in of just saying well
some of the names that I mentioned I
mean but his Seinfeld oh yeah Seinfeld I
think is amazing I love how much mileage
he can get out of everyday things I find
that beautiful and he's clean - when he
performed not that those who are you
know you can be suggestive but you know
that and I I have great appreciation for
Richard Pryor and Louie CK those those
kind of egg you know Eddie Murphy but
you know Seinfeld is able to look at
something and you go I'd never look at
it that way but I'll never look at it
the same way I got four right but you
talk about some guys who were dirty or
blue there's a lot of guys out there who
I think are great you know I think as
long as it's truthful and organic - to
who you are as a performer you know I
happen to do
to do it the way I do it but I don't
like stand on a soapbox and go everybody
should do it this way I like the fact
that different people are doing
different things what was that
any part of your parents being able to
see you and doing your act that how was
that the first time they saw you in the
audience uh the first time they saw me
was at a little comedy club in Fort
Lauderdale and I was I had worked my way
up to where I was going to be the
opening act I was going to do ten
minutes at the start of the show and the
club and all the other comedians were
were pretty dirty and so the club the
guy who ran the club Joe Mullen real
good guy knew that how I felt at it well
I don't want my parents to be subjected
today so uh they actually kept my mom
and dad it was almost like they were in
a holding room out front
you know in automatically seen yeah they
were hermetically sealed from any foul
language and then when I was about to be
introduced they brought my mom and dad
in and my brothers and sisters I did my
10 minutes and then they got them up and
escorted them out and that and now we're
back to the filth
but it was cool night and my mom and dad
were pretty proud of I you know
sometimes it's harder to do it in front
of people who know you
I'm fascinated that people who get
started now want to do it in front of
people they know I wanted to do it in
front of a roomful of strangers yes
because if it didn't go well then I
don't have to hear about it for the rest
of my life you know what I mean so
that's the way I wanted to do it but you
know now they have when people try to
get into comedy they have these
situations where you have to bring
friends or they won't even let you
onstage so it's a whole different animal
what do people say to you on the street
depending on where you are but what
reaction do you get they say can you
give me directions - yeah are you
recognized occasionally but what would
they do they bring up a bit a joke they
will
do that and what I think is interesting
is when they bring up a bit that's not
one of my [ __ ] I love it when you I met
a couple very nice people I was with my
daughter and we went to this shark thing
in Las Vegas and this couple came up and
they were like wow you're the comedian
right and I was like yeah you know I
felt pretty good and the wife said
there's not a day that goes by that we
don't go hot pocket which is Jim
Gaffigan together and okay but it's a
white guy yeah you know I'm fascinated
that she even knows I'm a comedian but
right when she said hot pockets her
husband went oh no no no and he's trying
to cover and she's like no no I'm swear
maybe twice a day to the girl so but I
don't even call him out on it I just
sure I go with it I just go I'm glad you
like the bit well I used to get all your
the SportsCenter dude I didn't you know
or you would get all Chris Berman I
actually had somebody say Stuart Scott
love your work and I go Stuart's black
okay like it really could use that be
like saying Hannibal Burres right there
right yeah right by stuff I had somebody
come up to me after a show no not after
show just in a mall sometime and said
hey man I like your comedy and I was
like wow that means a lot to me thank
you
and he said your favorite my favorite
bit of yours is your bouillon cube joke
I have no such a joke I don't know what
he's got and I and I said wow you know I
and at the time I made the mistake of
correcting them I was like well I don't
I don't really have a bullion cube joke
now I would go I'm glad you like yeah
and just move on yeah but at the time as
I don't have a bullion cubes oak and he
said yes you do yes you do it's the
favorite joke of yours and and I so I
learned my lesson you know I have people
who say I love you on SportsCenter I
watch you every morning they do that now
and and I've been gone for ten years
from ESPN and I just undo the point now
I go thank you thank you love I love the
way you do your honey thank you well
with Brian Regan he is starring we'll
talk about this Loudermilk on audience
Network Ron Livingston
it's a Peter Farrelly the Farrelly
Brothers TV series and then he makes his
Carnegie Hall debut on November 11th so
we'll continue with Brian Regan will
talk about the Irish goodbye I know I
heard you guys talking about that yeah
I'm on violin I'm on the king yeah king
of the I realize yes out the side door
yes in fact if you leave today you don't
have to say goodbye I'll be okay with
that just letting you know all right
we'll continue with Brian will do so
right after this on October 17th could
be a TV star along with Ron Livingston
Peter Farrelly's TV series Loudermilk on
the audience number channel 239 also
making his Carnegie Hall debut and
you're on tour right now yes you ever
opened for a band a concert yes I opened
for the outlaws which is green grass and
high tides forever there you go yeah and
I was performing in a city where they
were also performing they they didn't
choose media it's just whoever was
promoting the show so we need a comedian
so I went on stage and listened to
people yell outlaws at the top of their
lungs for 20 min history during your
entire so yeah and I just kept trying to
go yeah man they're great you know
they're they're uh they're gonna be out
here soon
oh yeah I know I'm with the I I'm
looking forward to hearing their their
show too
they're not out here yet they're going
to be coming out in a little while I'm
doing some stand-up guy rows so that was
fun I wish I had a video of that I could
I could listen to people yell outlaws
for 20 minutes do you have to be screwed
up to be a comedian
um I can't a good childhood didn't you
yeah you know good family life the whole
thing I don't know that you need to be
screwed up but you need to have a part
of your brain that's askew warped yes
you have to see things in a bizarre way
and you also have to be willing to
handle incredible rejection because it's
not going to go well every time you're
on stage and despair
see earlier in your early in your career
you know you're going to have some bad
shows and so that's you have to have a
weird brain to want to put up with that
but you there's a confidence level but
it almost seems like it's fake
confidence because it may go from city
to city where you go up there and you go
man I'm gonna kill tonight and all of a
sudden you had that one joke and you go
wait they missed it and then just does
doubt set in at all when you're doing
stand-up I try onstage to have a mix I
don't know what I want the audience to
think I'm completely confident yet in my
head it's 50% confidence and 50% faking
confidence yeah you don't I mean you
want to get up there and act like hey I
feel like I belong up here but you know
you can't help but have your your
moments of doubt you know especially if
you're 10 minutes in and you haven't
gotten much laughter yet we had some
people respond that we know some people
who work with the show friends of the
show and they said ask Brian to talk
about what people try to put in the
overhead bin on an airplane uh-huh yeah
I used to do this thing about sitting
you know I just observe you know just
sit in my seat and I just I just want to
do everything properly and do things
within reason but there's a lot of
people out there that are not interested
in doing things within reason and I used
to love watching people try to fit stuff
in the overhead rack that you know ain't
going in there in a million years you
know they have like a mattress and a
lamp and you're sitting there going what
kind of perception problems does this
guy have and the flight attendants are
always nice you know they always run up
and they're like oh I don't know if
that's going to fit you know maybe we
can check it for you and I always
thought I would last about eight seconds
at that job I would just run up and go
hey hey does this look like it's going
to fit you have this much room and you
have a dead yak you don't see all these
people waiting on you you don't see them
no no oh oh this is your world
oh it's all about you we'll wait for you
you captain
you know so it's just people just people
they feel like they can push the harder
they push it's somehow going to fit in
the overhead in their last last night
when I was flying here I saw a guy doing
it just with a suitcase just it's going
to get in there here this is the
suitcase
and this is the space and he just gets
at the flight attendant came up so we're
gonna have to check that he's like did
the last plane they put her that was the
last plane this plane if you can see
that doesn't fit in there
tell me about Loudermilk you're going to
be with Ron Livingston and its audience
Network Peter Farrelly the Farrelly
Brothers yes yeah it's an amazing
experience for me it's a TV series that
Peter Farrelly like you said is
directing it's called Loudermilk Ron
Livingston plays the main character
named Loudermilk and he's a guy who's
recovering from substance abuse and he
runs a small group of people who
discussed their substance abuse problems
I'm one of the people in the group and
then stories go off from our stories and
Peter Farrelly is just fantastic as a
director and it's a ten episode series
and it's going to be coming out in a
couple months and I've never done
anything like this so it's pretty cool
for me acting vs. standup
I was I was petrified the first day I
showed up
now that's petrified but I was like
nervous to do this acting thing because
I don't that's not what I do and he shot
he shot all 10 episodes like a movie
like he shot everything like and it was
so it wasn't necessarily in
chronological order the first scene I
shot was my most important scene little
girl like I got in early in the morning
I had to go to the set and I had to do
this scene where I'm reconnecting with
my daughter who I haven't seen like in
10 years and it's supposed to be funny
but also very serious and I you know I
do the scene and I used to stand up you
know when you do well you hear laughs
but on a set nobody's allowed to land
nobody's laughing nobody you know you do
your thing and they go cut and your
like cut like that like you're cutting
me out of the show you know like so we
shot it a few times and then that night
I get back to the hotel and I'm like I
have no idea if that was any good or not
Peter Farrelly called me in the room and
said hey man you available to have a
cocktail tonight and I thought he was
gonna fire me I thought I thought I was
so bad
bring your PlayBook you're gonna I
thought it was the Brig you know bring
the playbook and I thought he was going
to be kind and tell me face-to-face and
I was like yeah sure and I go down and
have a drink and there's other people at
the table like who were also working on
the show and then I'm thinking now he
can't fire me because there's other
people here so I'm sitting there the
whole time you know going when is this
going to happen and other people in our
ignite and now it's just him and me and
I'm going here's the moment and he said
hey good job today look forward to
seeing you on the set tomorrow like he
had no idea what turmoil was going on in
my head man I I really thought I was
headed to the airport that night do you
practice the look at you have with your
eyes like I remember your delivery I
remember that that stood out to me when
you would deliver and how you used your
face your eyes no I don't I don't
practice it I'm not even oh I made you
self-conscious now you're really screwed
up but but there was something about the
delivery the eyebrows that kind of
heightened what you were going to say
I'm more interested in the words and the
moments and you know I mean a lot of the
bits that I do are there scenes you know
just like the overhead rack thing that's
a scene that's totally a joke like two
guys organelle bar joke and so for it to
work I have to act it out observation
yeah but I'm not aware of it okay in
fact the first time I you know when I
see it it's usually like if I do a TV
spot and then later I'll watch it I
don't like it I'm going man I didn't
realize I look dead goofy you don't I
mean but when you watched yourself on
Letterman then you were on Letterman
usually at least once a year I was very
fortunate with that show I ended up
doing 28 of 20
the last year what was that was there
anything different about the last year
than the first time you're on
well I knew well that the second the
last one I did I thought was going to be
the last one and because I was on like a
nine-month rotation kind of thing and
then they asked me to be on like the
second to last week which was a huge
huge honor and he always took care of
comedians like it you know his stable of
comedians he it seemed like he always
had made time for you to to make him
laugh feels like being knighted you know
you remember one that really got him I
remember I did a one stand up thing and
I did this whole thing about standing in
bank lines and how they snake back and
forth and that awkward moment when it
starts to go back and you don't know
which way to look
you know you seen that person a couple
of times now yeah like like this
person's looking this way
do I look this way until I get before do
I look him in the ear
you know um so I had this I had a thing
about feeling awkward and then finally
being that guy and having this guy over
here and I talked about now he's the guy
who's in the awkward spot and I and I
the punchline was that he's looking in
my ear and I would say get a good Gander
idiot spot boy so I finished my thing
and then Letterman came over after my
stand-up you know he would shake your
hand before you went to commercial and
he as he was walking towards me he said
get a good gander it is my boy and I was
just it what an honor
oh you're ten feet off the ground you
know I mean like he yeah not only I
guess thought it was funny but to know
remember the actual words you know it
was very very rewarding you can see
Loudermilk on an audience network that
will be October 17th with Ron Livingston
unless I got fired as cut out of the
whole show
November 11th Carnegie Hall Brian Regan
our EGA n.com
with Netflix specials and also tickets
and for full tour dates as well thank
you again thank you thank you for
stopping by but thank you again for
something I bonded with my kids over was
and you helped with that you're thank
you're incredibly kind I know you had
mentioned me a couple times on the air
in the past and and and people have told
me about that and so I tried to YouTube
it and it's a huge honor to me that you
like what I do and thank you guys as
well man really appreciate it Brian
Regan and we'll take a break we'll come
back after this in the Dan Patrick show
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience